nous voilà aujourd'hui chez les samsung
pour parler des nouveaux produits qui
ont été présentés on a deux nouveaux
smartphones très haut de gamme on a le
note 10 note 10 puces c'est une première
dans la gamme note d'abord un grand
modèle avec un plus à côté de nos
discussions vous avez ce joli modèle
allongé de couleur différent ça c'est le
modèle noir le note disent pas si vous
voyez bien comme ça je vous mets tout
les incrustations vous allez voir c'est
top et là on a le le note 10 plus on est
donc ici c'est samsung on est
quelques-uns à venir travailler
vous avez géré sommes dans nos têtes qui
au fond là-bas des hommes
le bisou je viens vous dire bonjour
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui mais a montré
sa de coyron te montrer sa loupe à
montmagny pardon tu travailles
ah oui non j'ai prise voilà prise de
notes de jérôme six mois mois enfin
c'est déjà ce que j'ai écrit et andré a
écrit quoi moi j'ai écrit des trucs
dessus
voila voila c'est bon merci au revoir
monsieur et derrière on abandonne là bas
salat brandon on vient au monde comme on
travaille ici ça va à brandon
soit ces boîtes de chewing gum et toi
c'est quoi toi là-bas qui fait sage
aequo avec un petit chevalet
regardez-moi lalalalalalalalala ça c'est
beau bravo vous des professionnels
monsieur de taboth de schengen c'est ça
luc chartrand de machines et autres
freedent bravo on va voter un
partenariat rémunérés et rhinau
[Musique]
ok donc on en est là aujourd'hui pour
vous présenter ses deux nouveaux
smartphones de la gamme note sunai
dernière une autre note highly vol est
vachement intéressant dans
l'autoproduction vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool alors le truc qui change
un peu déjà c'est au niveau du design
s'est fait que vous ayez déjà déjà sais
pas s'ils vont regarder juste comme ça
le truc est magnifique j'aime beaucoup
la finition très beau très classieux
c'est vraiment l'adn de ce produit vient
d'avoir un produit vraiment au top
et vous avez surtout le poinçon qui est
au centre pas si vous vous souvenez avec
le s10 et es10 plus on avait la bulle
notamment semblé se disent plus que
c'est sur le côté ça faisait un point
sur son côté sur le x10 l'a cette fois
ci le parti pris c'est de se dire on
prend on le met au centre pourquoi pas
en tout cas ce qui a été raconté soit là
la partie celle-ci bien justement vous
êtes centre et vous n'êtes pas obligé de
décaler votre téléphone
il peut y avoir un petit intérêt et
surtout à côte un peu plus symétrique
bon pourquoi pas moi j'attends vraiment
surtout qu'avec le s rose l'année
prochaine on est enfin un une caméra
sous l'écran planque et ça je pense
qu'on va y arriver début d'année
prochaine ça sera une autre histoire on
en parlera en 2020 d'ici là pour
l'instant bien on va se parler justement
de ces deux produits qui sont
franchement cool dont je vous dis design
bien on a deux formats différents
je suis en train deux autres qui disent
c'est un peu la galère 6,3 pawson pour
le 10 6 8 pouces qu'on le dise plus le
successeur je dirais logique d'une hotte
neuf c'est effectivement notre 10 plus
très grand écran notamment dans cette
idée en tout cas fable est qui est
franchement hyper agréable
je trouve très fort et ça c'est vraiment
un côté très positif de ce produit c'est
que on n'a pas un truc massif on n'a pas
un truc énorme tout vous dites dans
votre finale c'est ça c'est
inconfortable c'est bien et même pour
moi qui ai pas des mains de bûcheron
vous tenez à une main comme ça c'est
vraiment cool tout sans plus et optimisé
avec du point de vue de l'ouest avec
manuel pour vraiment pouvoir l'utiliser
à une main donc ça si ça c'est vachement
intéressant dans ses rangs le point
positif est à côté de ça si vous voulez
utiliser aspen et vous voulez pas vous
embêter avoir un très grand écran mais
vous avez ce format là 6 3 pouces qui
est vraiment bien qui est très dense qui
se fait aujourd'hui dans l'air du temps
et vous avez malgré tout votre petit s
pen qui est là donc avec pleins
d'applications disponibles tout ça on en
reparlera du s prennent leurs deux des
phases de tests très prochainement dont
vous invite dès maintenant à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout mais
sachez déjà que en termes de design au
poisson au centre c'est plutôt bien la
prise en main est bien le smartphone est
à ses fins il fait très exactement 5,9
mm d'épaisseur ce qui globalement est
pas et non et même plutôt bien t'en
penses quoi jérôme ça vient ça non il
filme film film - film et moi donc voilà
pourquoi je me sens bien en plus le
point qui est vachement intéressant
c'est que vous avez depuis le s10 pas si
vous avez suivi à capteurs ultrasoniques
qui est positionné sous l'écran alors on
dira que les se dit c'est un petit peu
compliqué d'un côté un peu poussif mais
il ya eu des mises à jour et 5
intéressant que le capteurs
ultrasoniques ce qui peut être mis à
jour il ya donc eu des mises à jour sur
les dix ça marche merveilleusement bien
et sur le disent a priori c'est la même
chose du cantou cas c'est le même scène
au déverrouillage préval pid sécurisés
pratiques donc ça c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
les écrans à proprement parler comme je
dis donc vous avez un 6,3 poussez vous
avez 1 6 juillet pluvieux l'imminente en
même temps vous pouvez prendre le petit
papy n'y a pas de soucis sites ouverts
ici vous avez donc des affidés écran
infiniti haut vol notamment ici l'on
reconnaît bien ici écran qui sont
vachement bien si vous les deux ne
serait ce que par rapport aux notes 9
vous avez 40 % traduction de lumière
bleue on l'avait déjà ça avec le x10 et
x10 plus en début d'année continue avec
le note 10 là dessus c'est un écran
adamique amoled hd r10 plus vous avez
deux résolutions là dessus sur le
forcément sur les 36 2003 pourrait jouer
lire même temps je peux tout appris par
coeur 2280 par 1080 pixels s'il vous
plaît messieurs dames à 401 pixels par
pouce tandis que sur le grand modèle six
langues il épouse est à 3040 pixels là
1440 ici à 498 pixels par pouce dont ça
s'est plutôt bien et c'est un écran qui
d'un côté comme de l'autre occupées et
95% de la face avant
donc pour côté multimédia là dessus on
est vraiment tranquille écran de qualité
si vous connaissez les dalles de samsø
use avec l'être si vous n'êtes
absolument pas embêtés en plus quand il
est intéressant c'est que vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo donc si vous
voulez faire plaisir pour le côté
multimédia visionnage de la vidéo est ce
que vous voulez et autres cadets les
vidéos de monsieur gros dessus vous
pouvez le faire et en plus de ça vous
avez un côté un peu plus immersif c'est
ça qui est intéressant et notamment pour
la partie gaming aussi le fait d'abord
ce que tu as peu plus immersif et cette
qualité d'écran et notamment le fait de
pas avoir trop de problème de lumière
bleue c'est quand même plutôt bien par
contre certains regretteront sur ce
smartphone vous n'avez pas deux prises
jack ni sur l'un ni sur l'autre il vous
faudra vous contenter d'écouteurs
bluetooth c'est souvent la stratégie
vous savez qui est mis en place par les
marques les constructeurs à se dire et
bien sûr les smartphones plus d'entrées
milieu de gamme on va conserver cette
prise jack tout simplement parce que les
personnes n'ont pas forcément acheter
des casques qui coûte cher des casques
bluetooth
donc il ya un sens encore de conserver
ses prises jack et cinq sur les modèles
les plus haut de gamme et notamment ici
sur le nautisme 10 plus et bien vous
n'avez plus de prise jack
il vous faudra donc avoir soit
l'adaptateur vous allez pouvoir
branchez dessous why not pas ça très
très pratique soit effectivement un
petit casse en bluetooth
et là ça marche a parfaitement bien
d'autant plus que vous êtes du bluetooth
5.0 là dessus donc ça c'est plutôt pas
mal
à côté performances vous avez le tout
nouveau sac de samsung c'est l'exynos
98,25 9825 comme vous voulez qui est
grave et hans est un domaine vous allez
voir un gain de performance un gain
d'énergie plus d'énergie moins
énergivores en tout cas au niveau du
smartphone donc ça c'est aussi très bien
et vous avez sur le ne te dise un
smartphone qui a 8 gigas de ram tandis
que sur le nôtre 10 plus vous avez de
ziad raemdonck un peu plus boosté
c'est vraiment ça l'intérêt de ce grand
modèle avec ce grand écran scène si vous
voulez jouer par exemple si vous êtes un
gamer vous avez plus de fluidité 12 igad
ram truck forcément ça ça paraît quand
même assez logique et plus de stockage
sur le grand modèle vous avez soit 256
go de stockage soit 512 giga de stockage
tout ça ennuie fs 3.0 extensible jusqu'à
1 tera s'il vous plaît c'est ce que sur
le petit modèle petits modèles façon de
parler vous avez quand même
256 go de stockage par contre ici
absolument non extensible au niveau de
la batterie c'est pareil sur le nautisme
merci de 3500 milliampères heures parce
que sur le nôtre dispose d'une batterie
et julie nehmé santis achats de 4300
milliampères heures il faut savoir que
dans les deux boîtes vous avez des
chargeurs 25 watts fourni qui vous
permet d'avoir en gros l'idée de samsung
c'est en une demi heure de charge vous
avez une journée d'utilisation bien
évidemment ça dépend complètement de vos
usages de notre utilisation si vous
passez beaucoup de temps dessus à le
solliciter
fatalement vous le savez vous avoir
moins d'un moins de moins d'autonomie
par contre est ce qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est sur le net disent plus
eh bien vous avez une compatibilité avec
de la recharge rapide 45 watts qui va
falloir acheter en plus ça coûte à peu
près 50 euros après en avez vous besoin
oui non ça c'est à vous de voir et à
savoir que vous avez aussi un temps de
charge qui améliorait donc vous allez
passer un peu moins de temps à le
charger plus de temps et utiliser sa
société à 100 et en plus ce point qu'il
vachement intéressant vous avez de la
recharge sans fil sur les deux modèles
il faut savoir que le nôtre disent vous
avez une recharge sans fil de 12
5 watts ça c'est bien ça changera bien
et récusant le note 10 plus et vient
vous allez avoir une recherche sans fil
de 20 watts
il faut savoir que comme je vous le dis
en filaire de base de 1 25 watts
là vous êtes sûr du vin watts donc vous
avez quand même une recherche qui
suffisamment rapide en wireless donc ça
c'est vachement de l'oas parlons-en en
une on est sûr loin du ice pas si vous
le savez si vous avez suivi en tout cas
c'est plutôt bien c'est une version 1.5
qui est améliorée qui permettra de faire
plus de choses notamment de la
personnalisation et si au niveau des
boutons et faille pas mal de petits
trucs à faire dessus ça on en reparlera
lorsqu'on ne testera plus en détail le
plan dans la prise en main dans la
découverte pour le moment est bien
évidemment que serait la gamme note si
vous n'aviez pas ici le spn le petit
stylet magique qui vous sert à tout
contrôler le respect n'est ce pas si
vous avez suivi de l'année dernière soit
29 et vous l'utiliser comme une petite
télécommande pour lire des vidéos pour
prendre des photos pour naviguer ça ne
fait pas mal de gestes et possibilités
tout ça on en reparlera également
ultérieurement et continue ceux qui
m'ont aidé à faire son petit bonhomme de
chemin fer de plus en plus de choses
avec sur le modèle argent stellaire vous
avez un petit s pen qui est tout bleu
parce que son modèle noir et bien vous
avez un aspect noir
là c'est beaucoup plus sobre hop voilà
qui est juste là à vous de faire le jeu
contre eux personnellement moi mon cas
et dessus je trouve vachement mieux en
plus souple et le pilotage cac 40 mètres
de distance de cramer vous m vachement
moins t'as pas mal de choses de 6
notamment pour faire des photos à
distance ou des présentations petit peu
lointaine bien écouter ça peut avoir un
sens avoir effectivement 40 m le max
mais dans l'absolu pourquoi sachant
qu'avec pourrait effectivement faire du
dessin de la présidente il faisait même
un partenariat qui a été mis en place
avec microsoft vous allez pouvoir vous
commencez à prendre des notes
directement sur votre smartphone à la
main et ensuite sur word gars vous allez
pouvoir appuie sur un bouton ça vous
transformer sa part connaître en gros
votre texte bien évidemment ça marche
avec tout le monde sauf avec moi parce
que j'ai fait extrêmement mal qu'il faut
voir ça peut être intéressant mais ce
qui est cool c'est effectivement savoir
reconnaître ce que vous avez écrit ce
pas m a commencé à noter à la voir en
tout cas version numérisée donc ça c'est
cool maintenant au niveau de la partie
photo ça c'est très intéressant si vous
regardez sur le note disent eh bien vous
avez trois capteurs photo avant d'avoir
4 sur 9 10 plus savoir qu'on en avait
200 m2 et tous les ans au printemps
capteur que dans cinq ans on en aura 25
quand on est dans l'air du temps et ça
ça paraît quand même plutôt normal ici
soit le dise vous avez un grand-angle
c'est le capteur principal 12 mégapixels
avec une ouverture variable si on avait
vu déjà arrivé
les dernières ouvertures variable f1
points 5 f 2.4 ça va dépendre
effectivement des conditions de
luminosité vous avez un très grand angle
de 16 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 est
ce que quelqu'un sait le
ultra-grand-angle à combien longue ça
veut pas 123 on a donc selon ultra
grand-angle avec un angle de 123 degrés
et on a un tel objectif x 2 c'est un 12
mégapixels couvre af 2.1 tandis que
lorsqu'on arrive sur le galaxy note 10
plus
eh bien vous avez la caméra teuf teuf
tam of light qui va servir en gros pour
mesurer les distances à vous avoir plein
d'usagé avec notamment en réalité
augmentée ça peut être intéressant mais
surtout ça permettra d'avoir un des
photos avec un mode portrait qui va être
très juste parce qu'elle est capable de
mesurer les distances dans ce cas ça
plutôt cool ça vous permettra entre
autres de pouvoir faire de la vidéo avec
un éphèbe ok avec ce flou d'arrière-plan
contre servette aussi intéressant en
reparlera très bientôt on testera ça
ensemble
vous avez en plus de la super
stabilisation en vidéo vous aller encore
plus loin que ce qu'on pouvait faire
avec le galaxy s 10 et s10 plus
directement là dessus au niveau de votre
stabilisation et à venir filmer donc ça
pour moi croyez moi c'est vraiment hyper
important vous avez toujours le mot
d'instagram qui est instauré avec les sd
et s 10 plus c'est à dire que lorsque
vous allez partager une photo prise
directement il votre smartphone sur
instagram et bien ça va se faire
directement sans perte de qualité
contrairement à ce que vous allez voir
sur les autres smartphones android et
vous avez à l'avant une caméra de celle
fille de 10 mégapixels ouverture de f
2.2 sa smart phones qui est compatible
wifi 6,4 g de catégorie vin et qui est
dispo en france dans deux couleurs en
tout cas pour l'instant au jour j
aujourd'hui lancement vous avez donc
cette jolie petite couleur noire là qui
est très sympa et vous avez d'ailleurs
qui s'appelle elle le noir cosmos ou
s'il vous plaît et vous avez de côté
l'argent stellaire là on n'a pas
beaucoup de lumière ça peut compliquer
se rend compte mais vous avez un goût
plusieurs reflet ya un côté un petit peu
blanc miroir avec un côté un peu arc en
ciel c'est très très très très sympa et
vous lisez les semaines de couleur en
fonction des modèles que vous allez
avoir y ait d'autres modèles qui
existent un modèle rose est un modèle
blanc qui ne sont pas pour la france
également un modèle 5 g mais vous
comprendrez comme l'oiseau n'est pas en
france vous ne l'aurez pas si par contre
vous êtes encore eh bien vous pourrez
trouver le modèle 5 g je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient grand intérêt d'en utiliser
enfants d'ailleurs je sais pas vous mais
pas forcément france dans un autre pays
dans quel pays est debout et est ce que
la 5 gt arrivé chez vous normalement en
suisse
oui je sais pas si d'ailleurs si vous
êtes en suisse est ce que le modèle 5 g
sera dispo chez vous pouvez marquer
directement en bas en commentaire c'est
un modèle qui peut précommander dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs s'il vous
intéresse je vous ai mis les liens en
bas dans la description pouvait iec pour
me refaire votre commande et qui sera
livré chez vous à partir du 23 août les
tarifs dans quel état ils sont vachement
intéressant parce que on va avoir un
modèle de la gamme note en dessous des
1000 euros pour le nôtre dit ce que vous
trouvez à 959 euros pour ça je trouve ça
vachement bien
aidez vous voulez une note 10 plus vite
les prix vont monter un peu plus mais
c'est pas complètement exagéré après ça
reste quand même une somme presque
beaucoup d'argent bien évidemment non et
sur les smartphones très haut de gamme
très exigeant avec beaucoup de techno
l'intérieur ce qui va faire forcément le
prix va grimper sur le no10 plus de 156
cas de stockage des trains 1109 euro
puisque si vous le voulez en version 512
jega de stockage vous rajouter 100 euros
vous arrivez à 1209 euros et vous avez
une offre de reprise de 100 euros
bonbons why not soit intéressant alors
ça smartphones qui s'adresse à qui et
c'est à mon avis que je donne plus
intéressant on va s'intéresser à des
personnes qui veulent un smartphone
exigeant avec ce qui se fait de mieux en
gros si vous voulez vraiment des dont
l'usagé du stylet si toutefois vous aimé
dessiner si l'infographie c'est votre
truc si la prise de notes c'est votre
truc et bien c'est ce matelas sont faits
pour vous vous avez ce qui se fait de
mieux en termes d'écrans là dessus vous
êtes dans ce qui se fait de mieux en
terme de qualité audio alors ça je mets
des guillemets sur la qualité audio
parce que je n'ai pas testé l'écran je
le connais je connais les écrans
infiniti au ii de samsung ils sont juste
merveilleux
il marche parfaitement bien vous avez lu
fs 3.0 ça c'est aussi vachement cool
c'est un mass marines qui hyper exigeant
que ce soit pour du refroidissement
lorsque vous allez faire des parties de
gaming n'est pas vers un smartphone
brûlant on en reparlera bien évidemment
droit quelques jours donc abonnez-vous
comme ça vous serez tous vous avez
vraiment des produits qui sont des
produits d'exception des projets qui
sont très chers qui sont pas destinés à
tout le monde mais qui en tout cas sont
vachement intéressant d'ailleurs je sais
pas vous est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà des produits
de la gamme not not 9,28 notre set je
pense que nous parce que ce smartphone a
eu un petit souci mais nous parlons plus
en nous mais est-ce que vous avez un
risque dix se disent plus et qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ces produits là
qu'est ce que vous pensez des galaxy
note 9/10
dix plus est ce que vous pensez que
c'est bien qu'on ait deux formats cette
année 2019
est ce que vous trouvez ça intéressant
oui non pas comment j invite à marquer
tout ça il faut savoir qu un nouveau
service qui est mis en place par 5 fu
qui est vachement intéressant saper le
service et play galaxy en gros c'est du
streaming depuis votre pc
quelle petite course chercher le siphon
ce n'est pas moi qui les mets tu peux
passer sous silence alors que revoilà
l'adepte jeu blanc vous avez le service
le plein galaxy en gros vous allez
pouvoir stream et depuis votre pc ça va
s'afficher sur votre smartphone vous
restez dans la même partie allait même
sauvegarde même fier ça et que vous
jouez sur steam ou autre ça peut être
intéressant si vous aviez mais en tout
cas c'est bien et on voit que samsung va
chercher le gamer on sait qu'un gros
marché pour gamer course marquée pour le
gaming avec les smartphones de guelmim
qui évolué il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
monde là dessus et justement le fait de
pouvoir utiliser vos jeux pc directement
là dessus stop pour vous ça un intérêt
et oui non quand com - arkema tout ça en
bas on commenté à moi je trouve
intéressant j'ai vraiment hâte de
pouvoir les tester davantage pour
l'instant c'est juste une prise en main
les produits restent là je vais à temps
qu'ils arrivent au pouvoir les tester
les découvrir plus en détail mais tout
ça bien évidemment nos repas l'ensemble
fin août
mais rassurez vous y avoir plein de
nouveautés plein de produits plainte est
moins d'actu plein de choses dont vous
pouvez vous abonner dès maintenant voilà
donc ça je trouve ça moi ma chambre je
crois que je vous ai tout dit je vais
lui qui sont la petite liste
normalement on a tous vu on est d'accord
là dessus toi j'ai posé une question
n'est pas de savoir ce qu'il en pense à
un vrai copain
non j'ai pas fini
non non on n'a même pas encore commencé
ça c'est les secrets de fabrication de
monsieur go aussi aussi vite enregistré
aussi vite envoyé demain matin quand tu
vas dormir alors un petit peu ah ouais
bungie 3h30 transports voilà j'ai eu le
temps de travailler mais non mais il
faut que je fasse le montage ou dans
trois heures 2013 montage en trois ans
et demi mon rêve je vis ma vie
la banque est en pense quoi de ces notes
19-10 plus encore en trois phrases et
coûte bonbon une bonne continuité du
produit c'est vrai qu'on peut
s'interroger sur le fait qu' en mai de
cette année donc probablement qu'ils
veulent s'adresser aussi une nouvelle
clientèle d'une hotte pour découvrir
note est connu sur les formations de 3
pouces qu'on retrouve je dirais
classiquement aujourd'hui dans les
smartphones oui et puis un prix un peu
plus agressif après avec des
fonctionnalités quand même en moins donc
le choix
voilà si vous voulez le vrai note ce
sera le plus jeune a 10 plus chacun sur
note ouais ok merci je t'en prie et
wavre abandonné boss d'exception et de
la question pensent alors on a pour la
première fois
c'est historique deux smartphones ouais
outils et un grand ouais et je pense que
le petit il est très envisageable
c'est pas une version réduite c'est une
très bonne version 8 gigas de ram 256 go
de stockage de base à seulement 2 959
euros
c'est bien franchement moi je trouve que
le petit il a l'air plus intéressant
peut-être d'un gros qui est vraiment
très très grand et je livre une petite
guerre au grand téléphone
ouais je suis là il n'est pas près de
l'oeil il me fait vraiment de l'oeil ok
cool merci brandon rush compris voilà
comme ça je vous ai tout dit regardez on
essaie ça ne se joue entre un peu
épaisses de choron dans la tour samsung
au premier étage
et là vous avez dans la zone
d'expérience vous connaissez samsung on
a déjà beaucoup parlé on dort pas
d'ailleurs ultérieurement vous avez tout
le reste de l'écosystème ce soit ma
fille nahla née grand réfrigérateur
voilà on est plutôt bien on pourrait
presque se faire à se faire à manger
derrière avec la petite cuisine ça va
moi y est t'as beau temps fait pas trop
je sais ce film je sais c'est facile
mais bon c'est d'une tristesse absolue
bon c'est pas grave
merci à vous d'avoir raté cette vidéo je
vous embrasse vous dis à très bientôt et
puis rester qualité parce qu'on parle
des notes meuf ne disent pas dans
d'autres disent nos dix plus d'ici
quelques jours voilà bijoux à bientôt